chief White House correspondent John
Roberts good morning John and Sandra
good morning to you we don't have any
timing on that vote this afternoon is a
lot of procedural hurdles that have to
be waived but I am told that later on
today the Senate will be voting on that
massive two trillion dollar fiscal
stimulus bill the Democrats and
Republicans coming to an agreement late
last night here's the Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell on what they
accomplished it will rush new resources
onto the front lines of our nation's
health care fight and it will inject
trillions of dollars of cash into the
economy as fast as possible to help
American workers families small
businesses and industries make it
through this disruption and emerge on
the other side ready to soar Senator
Chuck Schumer the Minority Leader
sending a letter to his colleagues
saying quote we have reached an
agreement to address this public health
emergency support our local communities
and most importantly put America's
workers first here's what the two
trillion dollar portion of the bill says
130 billion dollars for hospitals 150
billion for state and local governments
350 billion dollars for small businesses
four months of unemployment insurance
for people who are either forced to
quarantine or have been laid off for
work and $1,200 check cash payments for
adults $500 per child that amounts to
$3,000 for a family of four there's also
access to some four trillion dollars of
liquidity through the Fed which is
alluded to in this bill but not a part
of the bill itself now on this idea of
when America can get back to work
yesterday President Trump said he'd like
to see people back to work by Easter
Sunday that is the 12th of April but
acknowledging that he just kind of came
up with that date because he just
thought it would be good to do it listen
here Easter is a very special day for
many reasons for me for a lot of a lot
of our friends that's a very special day
and what a great timeline this would be
Easter is our timeline what a great
timeline that would be my first priority
is always the health and safety of the
American people
it's unlikely that the country could
open up all at once it may be that
certain areas of the nation that are
less affected can get back to business
while other areas like New York City may
remain restricted I asked dr. Tony Fauci
about that at the coronavirus briefing
yesterday here's what he said you can
look at a date but you've got to be very
flexible and on that on it literally
day-by-day and week-by-week basis you
need to evaluate the feasibility of what
you're trying to do and join you asked
for you know what kind of metrics what
kind of data when you look at the
country I mean obviously no one is gonna
want to tone down things where you see
what's going on in a place like New York
City I mean I mean that's just you know
good public health practice and common
sense but the country is a big country
after the vote today if it is passed in
the Senate that fiscal stimulus bill
goes out of the house House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi with some definite ideas of
what she thinks should be in it so she
said she hasn't taken a look at it yet
she will later on today we're told that
the house is adjourned until 11:00 a.m.
tomorrow so it's likely that there won't
be any vote in the house so while it may
pass the Senate likely wouldn't pass the
house until sometime tomorrow if they
could even get on the bill at all right
when we watching John Roberts thank you